so let's deal with some algebraic
expressions that involve multiplying
fractions
so let's say that i had a
over
b
a over b
times
times c
over d
what is this going to be i encourage you
to pause the video and try to figure it
out on your own
well when you multiply fractions you
just multiply the numerators and
multiply the denominators so the
numerators here a c you're just going to
multiply those out it's going to be a
times c which we could just write as a
c
that's just a times c
all of that over the denominator b times
d
b e
times
b
d
instead of multiplying what would have
happened if we were dividing so if we
had
a
over
b
a over b divided by
divided by
c
over d what would this be and once again
encourage you encourage you to pause the
video and figure it out on your
own well when you divide by a fraction
it is equivalent to multiplying by its
by its reciprocal so this is going to be
the same thing
as
a
over b
a over b times
times the reciprocal of this
so times
d
over let me do that same color just so i
don't confuse you that d was purple
times
d
over c
times d over c and then it reduces to a
problem like this you know what i
shouldn't even use this this
multiplication symbol now that we're in
algebra because that you might confuse
that with an x let me write that as
times times d
d
over c
times d
over c and what are you left with well
in the numerator going to have a times d
so it's a d
a
d
over
b c
b
times c
now let's do one
that's maybe a little bit more involved
and see if you can pull it off so let's
say that i had
let's say that i had i don't know let me
write it as
over a
minus 1 over b
all of that
over
all of that over
c
and let's say
let's just let's also
divide that
by 1 over d so this is a more involved
expression than what we've seen so far
but i think we have all the tools to
tackle it so i encourage you to pause
the video and see if you can simplify
this if you can actually carry out these
operations and come up with a one
fraction that represents this all right
so let's work through it step by step so
1 over a minus 1 over b let me work
through just that part by itself
so 1 over a
minus
1 over b we know how to tackle that we
can find a common denominator let me
write it up here so 1
over a
minus 1 over b
is going to be equal to we can multiply
1 over a times b over b so it's going to
be b
over b a notice i haven't changed its
value i just multiplied it times 1 b
over b
minus well i'm going to multiply the
numerator and denominator here by a
minus a
over a b or i could write that as b a
and the whole reason why i did that is
to have the com the same in denominator
so this is going to be equal to b
minus a
over i could write it as b a or
a b
so this is going to be equal to
this is going to be equal to this
numerator right over here
b minus a
over
a b
and then
if i'm dividing it by c
that's the same thing as multiplying by
the reciprocal of c
so if i'm dividing it by c that's the
same thing as multiplying that's the
same thing as multiplying times 1
over c
and if i am
and i'll just keep going here if i'm
dividing by 1 over d
if i'm dividing notice this is the same
thing as division right over here if i'm
dividing by c that's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal of c
and then finally i'm dividing by 1 over
d that's the same thing as multiplying
by the reciprocal of 1 over d so the
reciprocal of 1 over d is d over
d over 1. and so what does this result
with well the numerator have b minus a
times 1 times d
so we could write this as d
times
b minus a
times b
minus a
and then in the denominator i have a b
c
a
b
and c
and then finally
we can use the distributive property
here we can distribute we can distribute
this d and we're going to be left with
we're going to be left with we deserve a
minor drum roll at this point we could
write this as d
times b
d times b
minus d
whoops i want to do that same green
color so you really see how it got
distributed minus d
times a
all of that over
are done